the iron banner is back Eric tay that is
man the reforged redux I don't know we
re something it feels different it's
different this time around I mean it's
still competitive right it's still
crucible it's still fighting against all
generally the more avid PvP folks in
destiny but it actually feels like level
and gear matters this time around yeah I
mean right now it's locked where you
have to be 20 and at least have a level
20 fire team leader to get in and i
would say that there's more 27 28 29 30
s than anything else but every
occasionally every now and then you'll
see that coming for that 20 to come in
and I have to say it's pretty it's
pretty easy to kill those guys compared
to like you're 28 29 because they just
take less bullets it doesn't noticeable
yeah cuz now the game actually will
factor in hey how much armor do you have
which is how much armor does that guy
have and obviously if you're 24 you're
probably gonna have a few hundred less
to ascend equates to less shots which
wasn't in the previous version yeah cuz
it basically felt previously it
basically felt you're in the 20s it's
all good even when we went in with a
level two and A three in the previous
iron banner was still able to get some
solid kills this time around totally not
the case when you took me in as a level
eight because that event was locked out
but if I had a fire team leader whose
level 30 in your case and I'm in there
rolling as a level eight and I could not
get one I got one kill in two matches
and that was cuz I supered a guy who was
at half health but I was watching the
videos and comparing and like previously
my like first assault rifle you ever get
in the game is putting up like 14 and 28
on crit hits and then this time it's
putting up twos and fours it's utterly
unplayable for anyone who is lower than
I mean certainly an 89 level I was
getting my butt kicked and I couldn't
really do anything to stop anyone else
and they put me down really hard yeah I
mean it I think they learned real quick
that that's not what was intended
obviously for like a level four level 52
role in there
shotgun and have the same effect I'm
glad they learned on that but it's also
funny just hearing you saying oh my god
i'm doing like a tenth of a damage to a
shield and he straight-up rock to me but
like we look at the old footage and
we're like oh we can actually compete
you know so good on them for finally
like figuring that out and i think
they've finally incentivized doing iron
banner just on top of like prestige and
whatnot they finally have the level 30
armor some new weapons higher rank this
time and for you it's a good benefit
because you don't get as much time to
raid and because you love pvp so much
that now you have a set pat on like how
to get at level 32 like glove and boots
absolutely like I'm at the point I've
got some exotic year so I'm not looking
to buy more gear from zur I got one
piece of raid year but now in order to
get to my level 29 level 30 I'm waiting
for Ray gear I don't want to put at
materials into my Queens chest because I
know it's not gonna be it's not gonna
hit that highlight level oh you know
your situation is different you've got a
couple characters you regularly rate
hard mode you're all kitted out but for
me looking for a reliable way to get
some gear that will go to light 30 it
will take me to that higher level the
iron banner is like the only way that
I'm confirmed to be able to get to do
that I time to get to level 3 and wasn't
gonna copy glimmer moat I remark I think
it's glimmer um but you know like you
said I rate a lot so like the 30 gears
not too big a problem for me but hey you
know what this stuff looks pretty dope
like the like for me it's gonna be
vanity like the gloves that you can get
equates to me having two wolves on my
shoulders which is pretty good at like a
badass I'm totally into that I like it
another the other big thing that they
fixed finally compared to the last
iteration is that you know in the past
leavers left because they didn't get any
benefit from playing iron banner right
you would only get iron banner rep if
you won so if your team's getting
destroyed why I keep playing you're in
it for the iron banner rep but this time
around they have a new medallion system
every time you lose you earn a medallion
of iron and then you can get up to what
five of those I believe you're you cap
out at five but it kind of like builds
up and then so you know you lose a
couple like man that sucks but then once
you win it's like you said oh man I got
166 representing
seems pretty comparable to it's not it
doesn't seem like it's exactly the same
as amount of rep as you would get when
you win but it's pretty close it's
pretty close and it's a I think there's
something in your mind it's a mental
thing it's like oh you see this big
number and you're like yeah like I got a
hundred fifty rep or something and also
remember wearing an emblem and wearing
that million million shader will also
give you a buff to your iron banner rep
so you want to be kitted all that stuff
out when you're doing any iron banner
stuff and I'm not sure how long this
one's gonna last is it just a week yeah
this one's only a week they've come out
and said it's a week they've also said
you know make sure you play this iron
banner get to rank five or however far
you can get because they're going to
wipe the reputation going forward for
the next iron banner event from now I
mean I'm certainly a lot more eager to
play iron banner because of the loot
because of the improved experience
system and because you know the quitting
has been minimized that was a huge
problem last time around it's good for
everyone in skoo I think some people
like that are at the higher end of it
this is something else to do now that
you know the DLCs a couple weeks away so
this is a fun little event to kind of to
kind of play now and yeah I'm having fun
and make sure to fill up your bounties
because you can double down now I'm
crucible and iron banner bounties with
that ten bounty slot that the new patch
brought in so get them all in there get
your bounties get your crucible marks
and get paid
you